ciao ciao a tutti ragazzi bevono video
troppo di jay z di sembrano rimasti che
c'era un uomo nudo sempre bello quando
finisco video che ci sono gli uomini
nudi e una cosa che sempre mi ha
affascinato è quindi oggi mi trovo a
dover riproporre ragazzi gli uomini nudi
minuti di penombra questo ci avete
contro i loro studenti
non mi piacciono questi buchi piacciono
agli uomini nudi basta siamo dati su
penombra parti schiacciava rimasti in
questo posto con la roba contesta
maschera antigas e qui c'è un uomo tutto
nudo che gira gattonando che lo lasciamo
perdere perché gli uomini nudi
chi è che ha rubato non ci interessa
nemmeno musica in word excel word
lo so lo so la levano riceve energia
bisogno di una batteria
ecco cosa che devo trovare puoi trovare
una batteria
chiediamo nudista se ce n'è una nudista
star non lo sai che preciso punto si sa
mai non si fosse meglio non trovarlo da
la trovo una batteria padova devo sicuro
superare il nudista dell'altro episodio
che sta qua porca vacca ma non ci sembra
che stava parlando ma che mi sedime
eccolo batterie non solo questo è vero
che fanno bene devo stare dovrei stare
nascosto teoricamente non ci credo corpo
demonio amarissima è fatta vedere o ha
fatto a vedermi è impossibile batterie
batteria aiuto a come così come ha fatto
ma come fa batteria o trovata faccio
giro ai a tema le ho finito tutti gli
antidolorifici che non ce l'ho più porco
demonio morto che male che male ma ha
fatto sto nudo aiuto veloce però
veramente ciò mi sta ancora seguendo non
ci credo ragazze muoiono ammazzo ma dai
porca vacca ma metti la la memoria
guarda mettila per terra
la morte il campo di tua madre ci siamo
ragazzi sono tornati con la batteria di
zia maria abbiamo qua dopo due ore
l'ho trovata però il tipo sta qua io
posso pasta vita io ha promesso 6 ore ma
teoricamente dovremmo avercela fatta
celo celo corrie allora vi ha posto la
batteria sta qua teoricamente questa
dovrebbe aprire la porta si spera o gesù
grazie
l'hack è male a penso se fosse mi fossi
non so parlare pensavo che avesse chiuso
la gamba e mezza board si salva qua
artefatto blu
questo è un freddo cilindri metallo
identico al manufatto arancione ma non
suscita nessuna sensazione di euforia
cosa me ne frega
dove stiamo andando ragazzi service è
entrato nel peggio cunicolo del mondo
anche la mia si sta cagando stanca il
mio riquadro che belloro questo mi devo
vantare diverso riquadro basta da alcuni
tipi di facili energia che galleggiano
in aria interessante mamma mia quanto
drogato sto gioco ma non ci credo
vabbè ma sto male ce li ho messi perché
ho detto va bene magia più magia può
salvare partita no queste sì così
passiamo alla partita fra bologna e l
lsp capito a quello è lo deve dire
subito dove sono questa la stessa stanza
non è vero sì però ancora non avevano
sfondato il muro quindi ottimo la tv
quasi nuova mamma mia come era bello ma
faceva cagare anche dal nuovo stop o
comunque facciamo schifo sio in quel
letto non ci dormirei a prescindere la
porta pure sembra la prigione di outlast
ho passato la porta
che strana sensazione per un momento
sono stato trasportato da qualche parte
dove la mia famiglia i miei cari erano
vivi e tutto poteva ancora essere
risolto o praticamente viaggiato nel
tempo e vi sono ritrovato dall'altra
parte di questa portata che figata
geniale no ragazzi sembra troppo la
prigione di atlas questa sera la
ricordate ciao sandra marchigiano vengo
da new york sono contente per far star
sfilata canti in cantina in inglese come
si dice kant in cantin
diamo incanta in queste pugliese varese
murray se io vorrei andare in cantine
che peccato
l'ipad è stakes e francesi questo e
canta più fresco e cambiarsi everywhere
immagini nei libri è insieme un buco nel
muro a devo usa devo usare le mie doti
da climbers e ditemelo subito come
facciano arrivare lassù tra l'altro
impossibile proviamoci
ma è strano artefatto aiuto sono
incastrato a ecco vedi schiacciare i
così in alto l'oriente finissimo
l'ultimo fatto a cantin
la cantina dei favi j2 basta porta si
apre non primo mica provato si si apre e
pirla stai mettendo a dura prova la mia
abilità di le mie skill da ninja secondo
me mi seguirà qualcuno io dovrò chiudere
la porta per bloccarlo e come del tra
tre secondi entra un tizio e invece no
salve non ti alzare per lavori io non
dovrei avvicinarmi ai cadaveri di vapore
caldo è stata probabilmente la sua causa
di morte va bene
tensione che c'è gente qua se quello si
alza mi cadde addosso anche se non fa
schifo mi fa però qua c'è roba che la
prende ragazzi la prendo per spiegato
sito ragazzo sito qualcuno giuro non
sono pazzo
cioè la b ma no allora ma chi è che è
stato essendo c'è il tipo di prima che
il dry atto sul lettino e vivo fra te
sei vivo io sento possile giuro ho
sentito tossire due volte parla mi è
difficile dire se vivo morto c'è un
badge sul camice che c'è il of carpenter
io ho sentito tossire ragazzi del giro
due volte blu e non una 2
penso di sentire alcuni storici ad avere
una persona viva in diretta hai visto
che non sono stupido in basilica che
un'ora che sento tossire ci sono passato
dall'altra parte a ma allora non c'era
bisogno di serve per prendere il piede
di porco che in mano che i dottori a di
gas per prendere piede di porco va bene
ed io sento possibile la cosa orribile
tu non sei sicuramente poveri che c'era
la leva per togliere il gas
vorrei avere tolto il vapore ai ragazzi
teoricamente prima di andare alla la
nord voglio prendere il piede di porco
te l'ho tolto e siamo fermi e per
cortesia la presa degli infetti è troppo
forte non riscatto via questo piede di
porco non mi importa non importa quanto
provo ma scusami ma se questo qua e lo
staff e io dovevo unire sarò io pensavo
di dover prendere il sangue un tipo e di
dover fare questa cosa
invece ora unico all'arte fatto la
unipol a medicina effettivamente c'è
ancora i fiammiferi volendo ti do fuoco
un'altra volta
che cosa ho io questa cosa non l'ho
capita se ti alzi io te lo do in testa
te lo giuro cioè un gioco che non va
bene poi aggiungiamoci pure la gente che
fa bordello mio dio
non so neanche cosa c'è qua dietro però
c'era del sangue quindi prometteva bene
grazie avermi indicato la direzione dei
condonò perché non capitolare partita
porca tua madre morta ma vaffan esteri
c'è ma ti pare salento non salvation
salvation grazie dio mio mi diventare le
frecce per terra lo vedo devo andare noi
che c'era bisogno delle frecce arrivo da
te mia adorata annabel jones ci penso io
ma vai tranquilla tili modo che tutta
insieme a pete facciamo tutti e tre i
laser projection punto exe tra l'altro
anche i trasmette di parlarmi stupida
vocina l'intesta inutile che dall'inizio
del gioco che mi rompi l'ex il quarti
mazzanti disattivata di rolo quanti
siamo
oddio capire c'è una ventola sicura da
ospitare allentato svitiamo la ventola
anche se non so 2 conduce a bosh dogma
bene e quindi is not a svitata la
ventola ma che ora ragazzi vi prego
mamma mia per non fatemi arrivare satana
adesso non lo regge ray biggin russa c'è
qualcuno tra fuori esattamente fuori del
corpo se come spunta una mano nel
condotto tra 3 2 1
non doveva andare cuore o forse sì sono
pazzo pazzo posso tornare di su perché
sono me stavo meglio l'agar agar agar
agar agar agar se questo paese è un
problema libro dico questo tornati sopra
grazie no perché non ce la faceva stati
sotto secondo i ragazzi mi sta fiutando
appena esco di grappa di bestia lo
guarda e se non c'è una ragione 3 2 1 e
invece ma chi sei
eccolo ci stanno due così che sta
facendo
sto vedendo così c'è qualcuno nella
nebbia
c'è gente nella nebbia ragazzi è bene
non voglio sapere io qua non esiste
c'era veramente qualcuno c'era qualcuno
c'era qualcuno c'era qualcuno c'era
qualcuno porco schifo non si apre la
porta a uno scoglio non si apre mai la
porta quando ci sto tizio qua non disco
mai a fare niente cosa c'è stato non sia
propone non succede niente
muoio muoio ti prego apriti ti prego ap
si apre non si apre niente muori da tua
famiglia tutti cos'è devo fare qua ma
scusami non ho capito che cosa dovrei
fare questo non si apre questo qua non
si apre la ma c'era un tasto che pirla
aia sculacciato aia porco a tua madre
morta
che male ei ragazzi il video e finisce
qua non posso fare questa vita spero che
vi sia piaciuto spero che in qualche
modo penombra sia tornato agli albori ma
credo di sì perché mi fa venire la cacca
come il primo giorno quindi io spengo le
luci e vado a nanna mettete mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale schiaccia della
campanella così stagionati suoi video e
noi ci vediamo come sarà anno possiamo
video da ragazzi
[Musica]